95 of your life is coming from observing
the other people and so your behavior
isn't yours how do we change these
behaviors I go first of all you don't
even know what the behaviors are because
you weren't there when they were being
programmed what did you learn when you
were in utero what did you learn during
the year from zero to one what did you
learn from one to two and I'm saying
your conscious mind wasn't working at
that time so whatever happened it's not
in your conscious mind and still the
significance about all this is profound
because well you don't know your program
95 of your life is coming from the
program your life is a printout of your
programs you don't have to go backwards
in your life you could just say Where am
I today and here's a simple point so all
of you out there ready the things that
you like that come into your life they
come in because you have programs to
acknowledge them but the things you want
the things you desire and you have to
work hard while you're working so hard
the answer is whatever that destination
you were trying to get to your
subconscious program does not support
that destination and that's why your
conscious mind is working so hard to get
there so I say you got programs and you
got them before you even knew you were
being programmed we have to identify
those programs because if you want to
change your life and you want to make it
one that has wishes and desire then you
have to assess what your programs now so
that you can then change those programs
and create the life you want need
motivation watch top 10 with believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Bruce Lipton and my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
rule number two accumulate knowledge
there's an old phrase number that is
just a stock phrase of the world because
it's true is and it says knowledge is
power and everyone's oh yeah knowledge
and I go no no
let me say in a way that might be
relevant to us now I say a lack of
knowledge is a lack of power
and I say we have been deprived of
knowledge of who we really are how
powerful we are because all the
knowledge we get in growing up is how
weak we are how vulnerable oh my God
viruses are coming parasites are coming
blah blah blah blah blah blah
everything's gonna fall in a bar and I
go well that's not true
it is true if you don't recognize your
power and I said well what power and I
go well one of the first things that
this empowered us was the belief that
genes control our life oh why is that
just some power us I go well simple
point
it says that as far as you know you
didn't pick the genes you came with
if you don't like your characteristics
you can't change the change you came
with and then I add this little last one
the creepy one that says well the genes
turn on and off by themselves without
you I don't want a life is relevant well
if the genes are controlling my life and
they turn it on they're turning on and
off without me I am definition a victim
of my heredity oh there's heart disease
running in my family oh I'm gonna get it
cancer oh I'm gonna get a cancer it's
him running in my jeans I go
that's a bunch of BS oh that means
belief system
why is that relevant and I say because
the idea that genes turned on and off by
themselves is the biggest false story
that you bought into which took away
your power because it says Change
Control you you don't control your genes
and that's why you look at your fate is
what James did my mom and dad give me
because my future is going to be
determined and I go
completely false
genes cannot turn on and off and I go
we've been programmed and turned on
cancer Gene turned on gave me cancer I
go no
a gene is a blueprint to make a protein
this and I go okay let's unpack that I
go the body that you see in the mirror
look on the screen see yourself all that
and I go that is made out of protein
building blocks they're about a hundred
thousand different protein types that
come together assemble them together and
I make a muscle cell out of some
proteins make a brain cell out of some
other different proteins so if I you
know try to tell the audience I say well
proteins are like Lego kit Lego Parts
they got a hundred thousand different
pieces different shaped pieces and I say
how you assemble the Lego can create a
muscle cell or how you assemble them can
create a brain cell a skin cell and I go
so the point about is this proteins are
the building blocks but proteins break
down so you have to replace them but I
go oh they're very complex molecules I
go
where do we get that the proteins when
they break down I go we have DNA I say
what's that it's a blueprint on how to
make a protein I go so what I go it's a
blueprint and a song I go
this is the story I always say so you go
into an architect's office and she's
working on a blueprint and I say lean
over her shoulder and go hey tell me is
your blueprint on or off and she was
looking to go what are you crazy it's a
blueprint there's a it's on and off it's
a boyfriend they go aha you're finally
gonna get it a gene is a blueprint it
does not turn itself on and off it
doesn't know what it does it doesn't
know why it's needed as no knowledge
other than how to make a protein and I
go but you gave power to the genes
that's what we did oh the genes control
me and I go no
it's like the architect story there's a
blueprint blueprint doesn't work by
itself but it works with an architect
who can read the blueprint and even
modify the blueprint and I go oh well
the genes of the blueprint then who's
the architect I go our Consciousness
is ultimately translated into chemistry
that goes into the blood
and that chemistry is what controls our
genes rule number three take your power
back it's time for us to wake up and
recognize that there's a program being
played out here we're in a darwinian
program because everyone accepts that as
oh that's the science even though
darwinian theory is wrong because it's
Revolution isn't on competition
evolution is cooperation that's the new
insight that changes the game of
struggle into harmony when we start to
recognize we all have been programmed
with a belief that uh if you're not out
there fighting somebody's gonna walk all
over you and you lose so you better go
out there and and struggle and win and
fight and all that and I Go Again a
garden is not a Battleground it's the
height of cooperation and Harmony and
what we have to do is let go and the
idea is the more you invest in the
existing program the more Consciousness
you feed that existing program The More
You broadcast the pattern of that
existing program and the only way out is
stop
does that mean I don't read the news
well actually I don't read it I just
read the damn headlines and that's
enough for me to go okay I don't I don't
want to be there I live in a different
world no I'm in the same world as you
know but I live in a different world why
well sometimes we have to recognize
maybe it's time to take your power back
maybe it's time to take your job back
and do something that is more in harmony
with your life I mean I was a tenured
professor in a medical school but when I
realized I I was teaching incorrect
information at Gene's control life which
is totally false uh I I said no I I
can't tell you this anymore
and uh and the Beautiful part about it
is guess what I'm living this most
wonderful life and I go how did I do
that I said I had to let go of the
programs that I knew I was engaged in
that didn't offer Vitality Life Energy
love if they didn't offer then get the
hell off of it because it sucks your
energy energy is life I talk about
what's called the energy checkbook and I
go what's that I go you have a bank
account that's the money in there is
your life I go yeah it is I go you just
don't write checks for nothing hey oh
Lynn what a beautiful blue sweater you
have here let me give you twenty dollars
that was really nice you know you don't
do something like that and I say we have
been giving away our energy
so much with no return coming back I go
what do you mean I said well you you get
into some like a political argument uh
between people and they go oh heated
oven
and they use all this energy and I said
and after the argument what changed
nothing
I said then what the heck energy is life
you just gave away your energy you're
losing life and that's when all of a
sudden I realized
invest your energy into things that
either enhance your Vitality or the
Vitality of the world in which we're
living because those are places to Build
a Better World to invest your energy in
the negative things and all that kind of
stuff like that you're building a bad
world with that and you're using your
own energy your life gets shortened and
so the reality is consciousness is real
it's a currency and if you use it and
spend it appropriately you can have a
much better life rule number four
eliminate negative beliefs negative
beliefs are equally powerful in
controlling your health as our positive
beliefs except in the opposite direction
a positive belief can heal you from any
disease
a negative belief can kill you
by creating any disease a belief can
create the disease as much as belief can
create the healing and I guess the
significance of this is profound because
nobody talks about the negative belief
and I go negative beliefs are powerful
this cause no sibo as you mentioned and
as I said they can cause any disease and
they can kill you just because you
believe you're going to die you can die
just from the belief just as much as you
are dying of a cancer you change your
belief and you can then heal the cancer
I go how I love this because a friend of
mine her name is Anita more Johnny and
she wrote a book called dying to be me
she had four years of cancer and the
final days of her life
in the final week she was so emaciated
that the cancer lumps were sticking out
of her skin because she lost so much
body weight and the cancer levels were
sticking out
she's on a machine for life support
she goes into a coma in her oncologist
who's been working with cancer patients
for years says oh this is the final
stage of a person before they die
so get in touch with all the family
members and say Anita is dying she's in
a coma this is a sign that's the end of
her life
and she has an out-of-body experience a
Consciousness change that the issues
that were related to her life had to do
with a lot of the fact that she was so
feeling guilty of upsetting her family
she came from an Indian family with
pre-arranged marriages and she pulled
out of a pre-arranged marriage about
three days before the wedding which made
her family look like you know
people it's like you broke a
pre-arranged marriage that's like
against the rules and everything that
irritated her father who she was she had
a lot of love but then that irritated
her father and then she felt she's now
alienated from that love
that's what precipitated the cancer
her out-of-body experience on the last
day of her life according to her
oncologist uh she had a lot about
experience of communicating with her
dead father who said no you know what
happened on that what happened on Earth
stays on earth when you transcend you're
not there anymore and everything's
wonderful and we love you and all that
she comes out of the coma
and the first thing she says I want to
eat something you know she was like give
me some ice cream and she was like what
you know
within a day she was off the machines
within two within a week to two weeks
there was no visible cancer anymore and
in fact the doctors were saying it's in
there somewhere and she kept saying no
there's no more cancer
and they kept looking after a couple
more weeks of looking they said no she
doesn't have any sign of cancer she was
on her last day of life with cancer
and a belief change
that she realized her father is not
angry with her she didn't alienate the
love of her family and and that thought
when she woke up out of the coma was the
placebo in a sense of the healing
thought that healed her from her last
day of life so people with cancer and
they're all struggling I go even to the
very last day the moment you change that
Consciousness is the moment you can have
the cancer go into remission and
disappear killing the cancer cells is
like oh I'm going to get those evil
cells and I said the cells were just
following the instructions that came
from your Consciousness you don't want
evil cells then change the evil thoughts
coming from your Consciousness the
cancer disappears so it's a power
that we have it's a power of our
creativity which we don't believe in and
I go okay
quantum physics is the most valid
truthful science in the sense that the
theoretical understanding of
quantrophysics matches every experiment
that has been understood about it I go
so I go well let me tell you the first
principle of quantum physics
that principle is
Consciousness is creating our life
experiences
you want to change your life experiences
don't change the world
change the Consciousness the world will
change behind that also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five use your creative
character people have heard of the
phrase use it or lose it and frequently
they're referring to oh well I can build
up my muscles through exercise and I'm
using them but if I stop using my boss
disappear and I go use it or lose it
applies to every system in the human
body every system is based on news or
lose it and most importantly the
creative aspect of a child is when they
were in child development that's what
kids do they they create ideas they play
and through play they are being very
creative but if we are doing what we're
doing now and that is programming them
with uh STEM Science technology
engineering math uh I say those courses
are not creative those courses are rote
memorization can you memorize the
equation can you memorize this and I go
if what has happened is our education
has taken the creative part out because
of finances oh yeah uh years ago when I
went to school we had Great Courses we
we you know we had shop for the you know
for the guys or everybody want to learn
how to fix and make things you know uh
home Mech uh we had music we had art
these are programs and most of those
have been sacrificed in budgetary
reasons to provide more stem and I say
then what have you thrown out of the
education I said the creative part of a
child's education has now been
transferred to the rote memorization of
science technology and engineering and I
say and the result is this
we are not as creative as a population
uh not that long ago well okay well it
is long ago because I'm old but uh the
the US was a leader in technology we
because we had the best education system
that provided creativity for the kids to
you know to move into the future today
the US is somewhere near the bottom of
Western countries in regard to
technology why we've lost our creative
character uh use it or lose it we've
lost it and this is a wake-up call
giving children back the exercises of
creativity because that's what engages
those brain cells and if you don't
engage those brain cells then they don't
develop and use it or lose it applies
rule number six practice positive habits
the most important thing about
transcending a program as I mentioned
before is identifying what the program
is and that's why I wanted to give
people an insight to their own
programming by just reviewing their life
and recognizing things you like come men
because you have a program things you
desire that don't come in is because you
have a program that doesn't support that
and I say well how do you change these
programs uh and I said there's three
fundamental ways to change a program and
it's very critical because the
subconscious mind is a habit mind the
conscious mind is a creative mind I go
what's the difference I say habit by
definition doesn't want to change I mean
if a habit changes then it's not a habit
anymore so I say first issue is this the
programs that we were downloaded with
are habits they were put into our mind
before age seven and then we just play
them like a push the button play the
program push the button play the program
not all habits are bad a matter of fact
you wouldn't like it without a
subconscious I'll give the example when
did you learn how to walk you learned
how to walk before you were two you
could be a hundred and two you're still
walking I go why that habit is there and
it doesn't change then so the first
thing we have to recognize habits are
not like open hey just change me you
actually have to like push a record
button to get into that habit I go well
how do you get a habit I said well how
did we get a habit in our life I said
for the first seven years we were in a
state of consciousness called Theta
which is hypnosis and we downloaded it
uh and the relevance about that is uh
Theta is a lower vibration than
conscious which is Alpha and focused
Consciousness Beta And I go so why is it
relevant because when we are working
like right now we're in beta High Focus
Consciousness School room kind of
working like that but when we go home
and relax the vibration slows down
that's called Alpha so we're in a calmer
consciousness
but what people have to recognize is
this the moment you close your eyes like
I'm just going to sleep Consciousness
switch went off I'm not in an alpha I
just dropped into Theta I go well
Consciousness is closed but Theta is
hypnosis so if you put earphones on and
you go to bed uh and you put the
earphones on and there's a program
playing through those earphones of
things that you want to be true in your
life uh you might hear some of the
program while you're still awake but the
moment Consciousness disconnects you're
in a zone of theta before you go to the
lowest vibration Delta which is absolute
sleep so every night there's a window of
opportunity putting earphones on as soon
as your conscious mind goes to sleep the
subconscious mind is going to take
whatever's coming in those earphones and
begin to download them because that is
hypnosis so that's self-hypnosis but
that by age seven changes because by age
seven now we spend more time in
Consciousness than in Theta uh and I go
but we still learn things you learn how
to drive a car you learn how to practice
with an instrument you learn all these
things I say why is it relevant in the
answers something like this how did you
create a habit practice you practiced it
so the second way of changing a program
is practice a new life if you don't like
the one you have uh yeah I like a new
age of people fake it till you make it I
go well yeah what does that mean I say
well I'm a miserable person I want to be
happy so I said but you're not happy I
said yeah but fake it what does that
mean I say all day long anytime you can
just consciously pass by you say oh I am
happy I am happy you could be miserable
I don't really care the idea is I am
happy I am happy repetition practice is
how you make habits and so if you keep
saying all day long I'm happy I'm happy
and you say it for a period of time
because it's habit practice there's a
day you wake up and you already started
happy because the program is already in
there you don't even have to do it
anymore rule number seven avoid stress
less than one there's a less than one
percent of disease is connected to genes
I go where the hell is all the disease
coming from
90 Plus
of disease
is stress
and and all of a sudden it's like oh so
I said well you can relieve all the take
all the cancer cells out I said did you
get rid of the stress no oh well then
guess what it's coming back
because that the the cells didn't cause
the problem they are a symptom of a
problem
and all diseases like cardiovascular
disease 90 has nothing to do with genes
you're not living in harmony you're
living in fear a lot of it has a fear is
the greatest cause of stress because
fear means I'm powerless that's what
fear means oh my God something's coming
I I'm a victim I am powerless somebody
help me and then the pharmaceutical
company comes and goes we're here to
help you I got another line of BS I
believe it says
pharmaceutical company isn't here to
help you it's a company it's a
corporation I say give me the rule
number one rule in law when you make a
corporation what is the number one rule
in the corporation's leadership and the
answer is your job is to make a profit
for the shareholder that's number one if
a corporation is not making a profit for
the shareholder then it falls apart
doesn't work anymore so I said well how
do you make a profit for the shareholder
I say God make a lot of money I go well
making a lot of money does that mean
you're going to help a lot of people I
go we'll tell them we'll help him we'll
sell them to drugs and they'll buy the
drugs and then we're going to make a lot
of money I'll say do the drugs really
work I go how many people are out there
because the doctor said your blood
pressure is high or your cholesterol
level is high and we're going to have to
give you statins statin drugs I go how
long do I do I have to take a
prescription of satin drugs and then the
doctor goes how long do you want to live
oh you want to live then take stat and
drugged your whole life I go
I can't take my whole life I said are
they going to help me now comes the
truth
statin drugs only helped three out of
100 people 97 people out of 100 have no
positive effect from certain drugs in
fact over 20 of those people will have
side effects that are disastrous so I
said wait I took the statin drugs to
help me with my cholesterol level three
people are going to be helped 20 people
are going to get sicker I go well maybe
we shouldn't sell the statin drugs they
go are you kidding me man that's a
prescription for life that means we have
a customer for a life
and I go nobody paid attention to the
side effects being more dangerous than
the the healing effect I go people don't
care because they're told whatever the
advertisement told them drug companies
they don't give a damn why because the
97 people that have no positive effect
from satins are going to pay them every
day of their life to take a Statin drug
I said is it going to help them I go
nope but they're going to pay for it
every day and a drug company's like yay
I could sell lots of Silent drugs and
you know what they did to sell more
drugs because there was a cholesterol
level and it said if you're above this
cholesterol level you need a Statin drug
like then what'd they do they kept
changing the cholesterol level over time
it was no no you have to have less
cholesterol oh all of a sudden it said
people that you know had a certain level
of cholesterol below the required part
no I don't have to take statin drugs
then I said no no you need a cholesterol
down here oh now that many more people
are going to take statin drugs every
time they lowered the amount of
cholesterol to another level there's a
whole new cohort of people that are
going to buy the Statin drug because oh
it used to be oh that cholesterol level
was okay now it's not okay now you got
to take the drug because they kept
lowering the level and every time they
lower the level there's a million new
customers for statin drugs did it help
absolutely not the side effects were far
greaters like five seven times greater
side effects than healing rule number
eight alter your mindset the
subconscious mind is yours not shared by
anybody else so it's not a common mind
for for civilization it's what you've
downloaded what you learned and how
you're you know playing in your life
your conscious mind though that's the
one that is coming from the field uh
where everyone else is involved and so
Consciousness is what connects us all
subconscious is your life experiences
it's used for this lifetime uh and
something as the new science revealed to
me which I didn't really know for most
of my life is that uh We Are Spiritual
entities I I was teaching genes you know
and now I start to recognize from the
physics that we Are Spiritual entities
uh and that uh the body is like a
television set my spirit is the
broadcast
should say television is dead and I go
yeah television's dead but is the
broadcast still there and the answer of
course it's still there and I said yes
this is the same thing with the human we
are not in this body we are receiving a
broadcast of field in terms of the
science of quantum physics there's a
field that's playing through us and I go
so if your body dies the field didn't
die it's still there it's like that blew
my mind because I said oh my God you
can't die you're not even in here and
then the The Joy about that was you also
come back again when another embryo has
the same set of what are called
self-receptors that are reading that
field for you each of us has our own set
of these self-receptors These are
proteins no two people have the same
sense so each of us is receiving a
different energy broadcast then let's
just turn it back for a second to the
subconscious mind the subconscious mind
is learned in this lifetime from the
experiences we have in this lifetime but
when you pass on and go back to the
field subconscious is gone and when you
come back again guess what fresh
subconscious and you start all over
again so the subconscious is used now
for this life the conscious is always
here it's involved whether you're in
this body or not in this body and that
is the Perpetual person that you really
are rule number nine connect with other
people I want peace on the earth and all
the rest of fighting all over the place
that means nothing
but if I get enough people
to say we want peace on Earth and we get
to that number and as Lynn said it
didn't start with a massive number
started with a small number but that
number grew why Buckminster Fuller
singer says Build a Better World people
will come from that world to visit your
world and what Lynn is showing we can
build a better world and why is it
increasing a number of people because
people are saying I want what Linz has
it always reminds me of the movie
they fix the orgasm in the restaurant
and another woman at a table watching
her goes I want what she has well this
is what Lynn and Brian offer they have
something to say they have something I
want what she has why because it's
empowering why
it changes your Consciousness your
Consciousness is creating
if the creation doesn't look good you
don't change the world you change the
Consciousness the world then changes
because of your creativity and that's
why
um Lynn's work to me is so important to
get people to wake up and say miracles
happen when you get enough tuning Forks
together and how many well apparently
eight tuning Forks is good to change
and Rule Number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is adapt
the universe is not a duality the
universe is a singularity it's all
energy and Quantum physicists refer to
this energy as the field I'm talking
about Spirit you're talking about field
are we describing the very same thing
invisible moving forces that influence
the physical world
very interesting we spiritualists have
always emphasized the will of God as the
Creator and the supreme authority of the
universe interestingly Albert Einstein
wrote that the field is the sole
governing agency of matter you say feel
I say Spirit you say tomato I say tomato
we're talking about the very same thing
in today's world I love the phrase
because it is funny but it's true
you want to be happy well do you have to
habituate happy you have to say every
day no matter if you don't if you're not
happy I don't really care you have to
tell yourself I am happy I am happy you
have to repeat it ah habituation
repetition why I'm consciously repeating
it every day and look at my life my life
really sucks oh Bruce I am happy I am
I'm saying that I go well why are you
saying it because repetition is how the
subconscious mind learns I say why is
this relevant and here's the fun part
because after I've repeated it a number
of times the subconscious says okay I am
happy as I've learned this I go why is
irrelevant that 95 of the day the
subconscious function is to make that
program real if my program is I am happy
the function of the mind is to make sure
I'm happy if the if the program says I'm
going to get cancer because I heard that
from somebody else then the function of
the mind is to make sure I get cancer
because that's the belief I'm more
working with
and if if it says I am a victim and I
can't get out of this
then the function of the mind is yep
look you see you I'm showing you you're
a victim and you can't get out of it
because I'm running a show you're a
victim when we're not really feeling
well is that a physical problem or is it
an emotional chemical problem well what
it turns out that less than 10 percent
of disease in fact maybe even closer to
one percent of disease is actually
connected to our genetics and our
physiology we have to say then where is
our illness coming from and the answer
is not from the mechanism but from the
Consciousness that is driving that
mechanism and this is the relevance of
the new science of epigenetics versus
the old belief called genetics they both
sound the same genetics epigenetics but
there's a revolution and what's the
difference the belief in genetics is
that when I say this issue this illness
or whatever it is is under genetic
control is the belief that genes are
actually manifesting the problem now
there's an issue about that as far as we
know we didn't pick the genes we came
with if we don't like the
characteristics we have can't change the
genes and then we're also told that
genes turn on and off by themselves
if you put all that together you're
recognized and you're not in charge of
your life your genes are controlling
your life well that's the old belief
because the new science is called
epigenetics and it sounds the same but
that Epi is a revolution for this reason
Epi means above so for example what do
we call skin
epidermis I said what does it mean the
layer above the dermis Epi Above So I
said then what is epigenetic control
means it simply translates does this
control above the genes
what control is that Consciousness your
perception of your world is what
controls your genes and if you're not
feeling well the issue is you don't have
to change your biology you just have to
change your perception and this will
then give you your power back and this
is why we have to recognize we're not
victims of biology we are masters of our
biology there's a thing called resonance
when something vibrates at the same
vibration they enhance their power so
two instruments are playing at the same
vibration that vibration is more
Amplified okay uh but here's the point
why does a patient come to a doctor and
the answer is because we have been
programmed to believe that's our source
of healing they never said what the
doctor had to do when you were a kid oh
you're sick we go to the doctor remember
nobody told you what a doctor would do
what did you learn that the doctor
provides whatever it is
so we give up power over our life
because that doctor's professional what
the hell do I know I'm just as an
average person so when it comes to a
truth which is my conscious and
subconscious mind when it comes to a
truth I give up power to the doctor
so if the doctor has got a lot of energy
and everything is energy that's a whole
different I wish we had another hour I'd
talk about that but uh the illusion of
matter that that's uh that's we look
like everything is physical and quantum
physics as a scientist says no
everything is energy so I say when a
person who is an energy source goes to a
doctor who is an energy source the
healing comes from the doctor having a
higher energy a higher more powerful
energy so when I walk into the doctor's
office just walking into the doctor's
office all of a sudden I feel a
different energy because that's the
person that knows and I don't and I say
so why is a relevant I said if a doctor
goes in not having a good day and
chiropractors know this they they can
practice for years and then sometimes
they go in and the whole day is crappy
adjustments and it's like it's not
working well I say well to forget how to
do an adjustment you've been doing it 30
years no they came in with their own
mind upping in harmony whether they had
a fight with their spouse or their
financial issues like oh why is it
relevant the person that came in for the
healing came in for the extra energy
that the Healer was going to give them
but if the Healer themselves have broken
energy because of the stresses and
there's all that when the patient comes
in the doctor has no powers very much
and that's why they realize geez my
adjustments didn't work and I've been
doing it all these years I go you didn't
forget how to do adjustment but when
you're touching somebody that's called
Hands-On healing and if you're putting
in energy that's less than the energy of
the patient yeah then the energy of the
patient comes down instead of going up
the physician heal thyself meaning
before you go in there and deal with a
patient they came in for your energy and
if your energy is not up to a higher
level then you can't boost their energy
you can only boost it if your energy is
higher and so the physician the Healer
the nurse more important because they're
even the ones I'm more importantly are
the more dialogue connected to the
patient than than a lot of Physicians
who hardly even notice what's going on
but it's nurses a lot and the age that
are doing a lot of the healing why
they have the energy they spend more
entanglement time sure and and therefore
that's really interesting so what is
healing I say raising the energy the
vibration energy is life no energy death
high energy a lot of life is the
physician the Healer the nurses the
attendant are they offering more energy
than the patient has if they do then
you're lifting the health of that
patient when people gather together and
have thoughts like a meditation on
healing or peace and love that when they
come together they can influence the
world around them in fact even the
project called the global coherence
project revealed that when people come
together and start sharing awareness it
actually changes the electromagnetic
field of the earth so our thoughts are
not passive they're influencing
everything in the world in which we live
so when people come together consider
this that each person's brain is like a
tuning fork sending out thoughts and
vibration and this is revealed in the
science of Magneto and cephalograph most
people are familiar with something
called the electroencephalograph you put
wires on a person's head and you could
read their brain activity but a new
understanding of how to read brain
activity magnetoencephalograph the probe
is out here
this is the most profound insight for
this reason if I can read your brain
activity out here that means your brain
activity is not contained in your head
it's broadcast into the field so each of
us our brains are like tuning for
sending out vibrations to the world each
individual has a power to their tuning
for it but as more and more individuals
come together it's an additive effect
that you have more individuals more
power and the more individuals the more
power and so as we come together in a
group
our thoughts are really being Amplified
and sending out a vibration and these
vibrations affect people who are not
even listening really because the power
of amplitude of these thoughts will
entrain people who are not even paying
attention because of this power so a
person just walking through a fear will
go feels it because we're all
broadcasting this energy and this is why
coming together in a community and
sharing awareness has power a very
simple point if I go outside with my
tuning fork right now and say Let There
Be Peace in the world I'm not
necessarily going to change anything
maybe not even anything right here in
the street
but if we get a large number of people
to have the same thought would change
the world and this is why it's so
important to understand the collective
nature of Consciousness that when we all
start to have Harmony we broadcast that
Harmony and the world will become in
harmony with our thoughts right now
today the world's in a big mess and the
significance of that is who's
responsible and it turns out it's a very
small percent of the population that we
would call the leaders of our
civilization
for me what would be really important is
this if all individuals would fully
Express their power guess what there's a
commonality to all people on this planet
what do they want health happiness a job
security food well if we're all sharing
those wishes guess what we would all
live in harmony seeking the same very
ends and so for me it is really
important that people Empower themselves
because our leadership is not really
supporting us as much as the massive
population because collectively we would
have a much better outlook on this
planet than the one we're experiencing
right now if I have a picture of fear in
my mind I'm afraid of something my brain
translates fear with different chemicals
stress hormones cortisol norepinephrine
factors that affect the immune system
that are called cytokines or histamine
so basically in a state of conscious
fear the brain releases chemistry that
complements fear that that chemistry
goes into the body's blood and that
changes the behavior and the genetics of
the person
so that means there's a difference
between having positive thoughts and
having negative thoughts and people say
oh that positive thinking doesn't really
work but that's not true the best
example of positive thinking in a
scientific study is called Placebo you
have a disease and doctor says here's
his new pill and it's the brand new is
science and it's going to cure you and
you believe it
and you take the pill and you get well
then you find out the pill was a sugar
pill so then you're left with so what
made me well it's not the sugar pill it
was the positive belief in that sugar
pill and how it's going to help your
life so that's called Placebo positive
thinking positive result unfortunately
most people don't recognize a more
important point
negative thinking is equally powerful
but it works in the opposite direction
so it turns out for example less than 10
percent of cancer is even connected to a
family lineage ninety percent of cancer
just comes out of the blue so to speak
but the reality is no it's a result of
stress and negative thinking so it's
important Point positive thinking
negative thinking equally powerful
because that's the level of
Consciousness that is translated into
the chemistry that controls your
genetics I just want to add a very
important point to this quantum physics
is the most valid science on this planet
there is no science that has been tested
more and verified more I guess so what's
irrelevant because the primary principle
in quantum physics is consciousness is
creating our life experiences and well
when you add epigenetics to that physics
now we understand the mechanism of how
Consciousness is controlling our biology
so biology and physics are coming
together to reveal that we are very
powerful creators of Our Lives patience
for a simple reason
you have to have patience in
reprogramming because you're dealing
with habits that will automatically
replay themselves every time you're
trying to rewrite a habit so you have to
create a new habit it's not going to
happen the first time or the second time
but as you become aware and conscious of
it every time a negative behavior shows
up and you are becoming more conscious
you are in the power position of
changing that behavior at that moment
and then engaging in behaviors that you
really want
therefore not only does it take patience
but it takes practice so you and your
partner in a relationship have to have
the dialogue with each other when a
behavior shows up that one of the
individuals is is creating and unaware
of then the other person must say look
you perhaps didn't see what you just
said or what you just did automatic
subconscious Behavior Uh it wasn't
really the best thing and through a nice
dialogue and through practice what you
can end up is again leading to an
opportunity to engage with each other
and as a result create new programming
that supports both your wishes and
desires and aspirations and this is the
next and last step of putting that
honeymoon relationship back together
so in conclusion what can we say about
this whole honeymoon effect is this
number one people talk about mind-body
interactions and mind controlling life
and while a lot of people say my mind
wouldn't have created this life
you can go back to a point where you
fell in love and recognize a very simple
truth what you created was not an
accident it was an activation of your
conscious wishes desires and aspirations
you already did create heaven on Earth
the issue is what happened to it and I
said ah the interference from the
subconscious mind if you understand the
programming and how that programming is
the default behavior and you understand
how you can rewrite that programming
then you're given an opportunity to
eliminate the negative programs in your
subconscious that have been sabotaging
you and instead replace them with
behaviors that correspond with your
wishes and desires and when you do that
the so that your conscious mind and your
subconscious mind have the same program
then guess what
at that moment whether you're paying
attention or whether you're not paying
attention you'll be engaged in the
honeymoon experience it never has to go
away The Honeymooners experience that
you could have your whole life this is
why we were here we were here to create
heaven on Earth the one time you did it
is when you fell in love
it could have stayed that way if you
understood the mechanisms we have
described here
but when you do understand the
mechanisms it says you can go back and
recreate that and make it a permanent
way of life you were born into heaven
you've experienced it once or more and
you can do it again and again and again
because that's how powerful you are you
are a Creator and you are in heaven when
you use your creation you will manifest
Heaven every day in your life and enjoy
the beauty of a living experience on
this wonderful Planet why does stress
cause so much disease I'll tell you why
stress you're running away from that
saber-toothed tiger whatever's
threatening you and I say what is stress
anything that gets in the way of where
you want to go is a stressor I say so
why is that relevant I go because that's
like in the mind the saber-toothed tiger
and you want to run that's what fight or
flight and I said but you use your arms
and legs I go yeah but that I need the
energy I said the blood carries the
energy so I say so what when the stress
hormones come into the body you want the
body to put the blood into the arms and
legs because you're going to have to run
that's what fear and stress is about
okay so what do you mean put isn't it in
the arms of life cycle yeah but most of
the blood is in your gut I say what's
the gut all the organs of Maintenance
take care of your health fix the blood
you know aerate clean all that stuff I
go yeah but when you're in stress I
don't need to take care of myself I got
to run away from the tiger so stress
hormones number one shut off the blood
vessels in the gut and I said that's
like butterflies in the stomach when you
feel that fear that's the stress
hormones causing the blood vessel
squeeze I said so why would you do that
because then the blood is pushed to the
arms and legs that's where most of the
energy is needed that's number one so
you compromise Health just by having
stress hormones because you're shutting
it off the maintenance but number two
the immune system uses a lot of energy
that's why when people are sick
sometimes they can't even get out of bed
I say so if I'm being chased by a
saber-toothed tiger and I got a
bacterial infection how do I want to you
know split the energy and I go the hell
with a bacterial infection that
saber-toothed tiger catches you bacteria
is not your problem anymore so guess
what stress hormones by function shut
down the immune system and I go and it's
so effective that when doctors want to
transplant a foreign organ into a
recipient and they don't want the
recipient's immune system to reject the
foreign organ before they do the
transfer they give the recipient stress
hormones to shut off the immune system
so it doesn't reject the foreign organ I
say this stress hormones are so
effective at shutting it off they use it
therapeutically to shut it off and I go
why is it relevant because our entire
world is in such stress all the time
that they're dripping stress hormones
and I say what are they doing they're
shutting off the growth and maintenance
of the body they're shutting down the
immune system I say net result illness
and death from stress and that is why up
to 90 percent of illness comes from
stress because the chemistry of [ __ ] of
stress redirects your energy to run not
to be conscious and aware and healthy
very important part of our understanding
about life is that it's our perception
of Life which actually means our beliefs
about life so the significance is if
you're going to plan your life and
you're going to make perceptions the
programmer of your life well then the
best thing you can do is perceive of the
life that you would wish and desire
because those thoughts will be
translated by biology into the
expression of your cells and your
genetics and you will manifest your
wishes and your desires and that's what
the new biology is all about please
listen to this
a negative thought is equally powerful
in controlling the biology so as much as
a positive thought can heal you a
negative thought can kill you it can
make any disease you can have a negative
thought about cancer and manifest cancer
you have no no genes or even cancer
related genes and it's like where the
hell did it come from you are creating
your biology as a complement to what you
see
so if you see a positive world then
you're getting Positive Vibes coming in
and it feels really great and if you
live in a negative world or one you
believe to be negative then the cells
are inside cowering going oh my God it's
not safe out there uh and and so my
cells are just adjusting to my
perception so changing your perception
is like well where's that and I go
that's your mind take care of yourself I
say what do you mean first of all take
care of your system it will manage this
virus without killing you but first of
all you have to make sure your blood has
proper nutrition you need to be healthy
in the system and our diet is so
compromised within oh yeah food and
garbage food that I have to tell people
you've got to go back and eat natural
you have to go back and eat organic
because industrial Farm stuff is filled
with chemistry that is is causing you
more problems
number two take vitamins and supplements
why especially vitamin C and vitamin D
these enhance the immune system lots of
vitamin C Way Beyond whatever
relationship you met Linus Pauling yes
you know and it's interesting because I
lectured at his uh Institute when I was
at Stanford wow and it was interesting
because the science has revealed that
massive doses I take two grams of
vitamin C every morning high five
and the relevance about that is I'm also
you know I'm what am I trying to do
de-stressing I'm not stressed I live in
another world I walk out the door I
don't live in that world of the people
around me they're the ones that are
stressed I'm like I'm not stressed I'm
okay I'm 76 am I afraid because I'm old
[ __ ] BS belief system excuse me uh
uh that um I'm not afraid to go outside
I I eat well I take vitamins and
supplements hey
do work exercise something to keep the
body moving because that enhances the
Vitality of the circulatory system which
is delivering immune function so eat
well vitamin supplements you exercise
and number four most important do not
put the fear in your head
because the function of the mind is to
manifest whatever you believe and if you
start to believe in the fear then the
function of the mind is to manifest that
fear and that's why the whole idea is
shut off the damn TV and don't listen to
these people because they are
disempowering you
with fear
and fear is where you lost your power
because once you do fear as you shut
yourself off and you can't shut yourself
off we you're connected to a world you
can't live in a bubble you'll die
and the idea is if you buy the fear you
are putting up walls around you because
you want to protect I'm protecting here
I say walls are the opposite of growth
growth you have to open yourself up
things in okay and uh and fear as you
shut everything down another major
assumption is that we're equivalent to
genetic automatons we have genes they
control us we don't control the genes
and therefore we're sort of like victims
of our heredity you got cancer running
in your family say oh my goodness I'm
going to get the cancer I got the genes
or Alzheimer's or diabetes whatever this
is completely false because it turns out
genes control nothing it's really the
environment that is controlling the
genes and more importantly our purse
perception of the environment how we see
the world what we think about the world
is adjusting our genetics so we find out
disease one percent of disease is
connected to genetics ninety percent or
more of diseases connected to how we
live in the world because how we live in
the world is uh altering or affecting
our genetic activity so what we know and
what we believe is changing our reality
constantly right because the new
scientists called epigenetics and what
it means is this our beliefs and how we
see the world
we change our genetics so and rather
than being victims which we have
believed all the way up to now we are
the Masters we change our genetics just
by how we respond to the world so we can
change our responses which means then we
can change our genetics so we're not
victims I am so grateful to offer this
because as each one of us takes back our
power and each one of us actually starts
to live heaven on Earth like you did
when you fell in love even if it was
only for a week if you could do that
every day of your life and everyone
around you was doing that every day of
your life then the simple truth is this
and Earth does become Heaven if we're
all living as if it's Heaven and the
function is to create the minds is to
take that vision and manifest it if I
believe I'm living in heaven then my
world experience will be what would it
be like if I lived in heaven and being
in love is the one time you
unconsciously unknowingly
took back power the equivalent of the
red pill you unknowingly became powerful
and I said yeah in 24 hours you changed
your whole demeanor of life after you
met this person yeah I go
you you could have done it in different
ways didn't have to be with a person you
didn't need to fall in love with a
person you could fall in love with uh
gardening yeah if you're a gardener you
go out in the garden and you're digging
the garden you're having so much fun and
the plants are growing and everything I
go you just manifested heaven on Earth
for you it's not beautiful living in the
garden I go well it doesn't have to be
another person the love doesn't love Is
Just focusing on something you desire
a pet a garden artwork cleaning up the
garage
yeah because when I'm doing it I'm
creating order and happiness and all
that I go well fine then you're cleaning
out the garage I go to clean up the damn
garage so if you're cleaning up because
wow that's so much better now I feel so
much better in here it's so clean I know
where everything is I go
being in love doesn't have it could be
anything that keeps your conscious mind
in front because it's when your
conscious mind goes in the back is when
you become the product of your
subconscious program
so
um and this is great perception can
rewrite the genetic code when you're
under stress you will rewrite your genes
it's built into every one of your cells
you have genetic engineering genes the
function of these genes is if you find
stress that the body cannot seem to get
out of the body will make an effort to
change its structure to get out of the
problem
and of course the issue is this what if
your perception wasn't real and you
change your genes now you're in deep
doo-doo
and we now find a very important fact
95 percent of cancer has no genetic
linkage
95 of cancer is a response of the
individual cells to their experiencing
life
and if you change your experiences you
can change the presence of that cancer
that's how it works how did you learn
anything after age seven the answer was
repetition that's what it was was just
practicing the more you repeat something
the more it becomes just so easy you
don't know how to play an instrument you
practice like crazy at some point you
practice so much you pick up the
instrument no consciousness of the
details of how you're playing it it's so
automatic at this point it's like
driving the car
when you first got in the cars like oh
my God you've got to watch the window
the mirrors the gauges the engine sound
every yes like so much today you've been
driving a car a long time guess what
you don't even think about it but the
key in you're thinking about where
you're going and all of a sudden I saw
the more you practice the less effort it
takes to carry out whatever it was you
were practicing now the question is what
are you practicing something positive or
something negative because they're both
become programs whichever one you're
practicing what we now know is the
conscious mind if you stay in the
conscious mind
you have power
but if the conscious mind is thinking it
is not using its power to interfere with
the uh enact with the outer world
thinking is using the power to go to the
inner world so a thought is not outside
a thought is inside yeah but the
conscience is reading a thought so I
said what does that mean I said well the
conscience is helping me create this
world oh wait wait the moment I'm
thinking
I have to take that Consciousness
redirected not look out but redirect it
because thinking is inside so I said
well what does that mean I said well the
moment you were thinking you were not
creating your world at this moment I
said what does that mean I say if you're
driving the car and all of a sudden you
start thinking what it means is you're
not looking out the window anymore you
are now looking inside because answers
for thoughts are on the inside then you
go oh my God you stop looking out the
window the car is going to crash and
they go
cool part or not yeah the subconscious
is autopilot so the moment Consciousness
is not paying attention
the subconscious Takes the Wheel
but now comes the problem
the subconscious is not you it's the
program so if I got bad driving
instructions
then when the subconscious takes the
wheel as autopilot it's going to take me
down the road to ruin it's not going to
take me to where conscious says I want
to have this wonderful success but my
program is you're not worthy you're not
smart enough you're not deserving so
when that program grabs the wheel it's
not going to take me to success it's
going to take me to where the program
goes so if I disempower you in your
programming and 95 percent of your life
comes from that
the rest of your life is struggle and
it's not because you couldn't create it
it's just you didn't realize that this
subconscious guy is working 95 percent
of the time and you don't see it and
this is where how come life seems to be
a struggle from the outside coming in
when it's like oh my God you didn't get
it you're creating both success and
you're creating failure it's not coming
from outside if you change the picture
in your mind you change the chemistry
you change the Fate so I'll give an
example
if I have a picture of Love in My Mind
the brain releases complementary
chemistry dopamine pleasure oxytocin
bond with your loved one growth hormone
which does exactly what it says that
enhances your growth and that's why when
people fall in love the chemistry of the
brain going into the blood the culture
medium enhances Vitality people glow
when they fall in love people are
healthy when they fall in love it's not
an accident it's the chemistry of your
culture medium but now I say but wait
what if I have a picture of fear I go oh
well love chemistry doesn't come out
when fear is in the picture the brain
releases stress hormones and factors
that affect the immune system and growth
of the system and I go oh my goodness I
say why is it relevant changing my
thought changes my chemistry the
chemistry adjusts my biology so if I can
control my thoughts I can control the
chemistry and therefore I control the
biology that takes me to empowerment
Mastery after being programmed by
medicine and biology all these years
that you're just a victim of your genes
that's 100 false genes cannot turn on
and off by themselves they're controlled
by the signals of the environment which
are then controlled by the brain and the
Consciousness and all of a sudden it
says yeah but I control those things I
go yes you do and as a result you have
power
to heal yourself and create what you
want on this planet just to begin with a
very interesting concept that
um
judeo-christianity has provided the
large population of the world with a
belief that Genesis occurred and God
created the planet and the water and
then the animals and the plants and
after all this creation then God said
let's add some humans to the mix so we
didn't come from that creation we were
added to the Earth
science comes in and also separates us
from the planet because conventional
science based on what is called
Newtonian physics we are physical
particles separate from each other no
we're all separate pieces and we lost
the understanding that the word Gaia
is a living organism the Earth is a cell
we are connected to everything we've
lost that Vision we feel that we are a
peace in a in a bunch of pieces and as I
said are we going to be safe or are we
going to be afraid in this and I said
then we want to protect ourselves and if
you understand the breathing of most
people it's very shallow it's right up
here why I don't want to take too much
of the outside in I'm protecting myself
but as you said we we still need oxygen
so we breathe in a little bit of oxygen
but we want to be separate
and the simple reality is those beliefs
are totally false we were created with
everything we are created from
everything there is no separation
between us and the world in which we
live
and so when we are breathing very
shallow we are actually remember I said
protection close yourself down shallow
breathing closing yourself down when you
start to learn to take in the breath of
life you are opening yourself to the
entire world around us
and that opening of the world makes us
part of this world not A Separate Peace
from one another
so breathing becomes a very important
part of am I hiding from the World by
just breathing a little tiny bit or can
I take in this breath and become part of
this Oneness that we are your separation
is where all the problems of life come
from
your breathing can open you up
to this entire world to take it in you
are this world you are every bit of this
you're a reflection of everything out
there you came from that
so basically can we stop the protection
that we think is helping us but it's the
protection that is killing us
and breathing can I take this in
can I take the world in yes
and I can Thrive and so when we start to
let go of that protection the breathing
will start to go from shallow chest to
abdominal because I'm taking in the
world with every breath I'm taking in
the energy of the world with every
breath and that is what makes us whole
you have shallow breathing you have fear
all of a sudden you cannot be whole
anymore
and so we come here to learn to take
power back
and and oh my God Closing word yoga
[Music]
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome to learn about the law of
attraction Secrets check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there then I'm gonna feel so great now
that well then they're back to the
program waiting for it to happen for
them to feel the emotion they're
believing their outer world has to
change in order for them to feel better
there's there's no